welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and we finally know what exactly
happened when Sylvie killed he who
remains in the Loki season 1 finale and
what her next move is in the upcoming
Looking season two it's Mickey D's baby
the series executive producer finally
shed some light on what the hell is
going on with his Loki season 2
McDonald's partnership and boy howdy it
all makes so much sense with the
confusing play season one left off
questions that we now have answers to so
what exactly did Sophie do with the
Multiverse and why here and why now is
she working in the golden arches in
1982. hey quick reminder I broke down
the first season of Loki over on the
Deep dive Channel and Unearthed a lot of
cool stuff in that videos please go
watch it and subscribe to all three of
the channels of the new rockstars
Network please and thank you okay you
remember a few weeks back Marvel's Loki
and McDonald's released this bizarre
promo for the new Loki sweet and sour
sauce with a scene that is in the
upcoming season of Loki
so we hear the music of Moon River which
was sung by Audrey Hepburn in Breakfast
at Tiffany's and later covered by Andy
Williams and Mobius goes for some apple
pie while standing with captured variant
Brad wolf who's an actor in the zaniac
film Loki executive producer Kevin
Wright told bass company in an interview
what's going on with Sylvie in the scene
revealing that this is the first time
Loki and Sylvia are seeing each other
since the season one finale and that
Sylvie came here to work in a 1982
McDonald's directly after stabbing he
who remains and splintering the
Multiverse he said this character had
been on a decades-long maybe
centuries-long Revenge mission in the
classic Trope of those stories is that
it's all consuming and she's not
thinking about what comes next now she
has this moment of opportunity where is
she going to go we stayed in the view of
character this woman who went on the run
as a child had been running through time
a fugitive of time living in apocalypses
never being able to relax or slow down
the novelty of walking up to a 19 ladies
McDonald's looked appealing he played a
little league game and go to McDonald's
you go to a kid's birthday party at
McDonald's someone like Sylvie would
never have experienced that and would be
really taken by that this article states
that rather than McDonald's approaching
Marvel for product integration a 1982
McDonald's was written into the script
and that when Wright approached Marvel's
Partnerships team he was told Marvel
already had a deal in the works of
McDonald's and that this would make it
better he said quote I was worried that
McDonald's would think we wanted to do
something ironic or make fun of them but
we were selling an Earnest story a love
letter to Nostalgia through a
character's eyes who will see all the
novelty and joy of it whoa so this idea
of Sylvie being on her TVA Revenge
mission for centuries is haunting now as
Guardians and frost giant like Loki and
Sylvia in their variants are known to
live for Millennia 5 000 years or so so
it's not a huge chunk of their lives but
it tells us that it wasn't just a few
dozen different apocalyptic events that
Sylvie hid out in one after the other
but rather hundreds potentially
thousands of them most of which she
would have had to cycle back through
re-experiencing the most traumatic
events in the history of intelligent
species again and again and again
becoming desensitized to them and
becoming an all-knowing master of those
apocalypses kind of like Bill Murray and
Groundhog Day if all of these disasters
were scripted by the Kang variant he
remains Sylvie would be the person
forced to read and to experience that
script again and again and again until
she became even more absorbed in that
fiction than the author himself who
wrote it turning her into kind of a
voracious reader turned sociopathic
stalker like Kathy Bates and misery of
course she was going after the author to
kill him and so yes for a variant robbed
of her childhood it's not a Shameless
grasp for ad Revenue well it kind of is
but it's mostly for this character to
yearn for the simple joys of American
Suburbia that she was never able to
experience like when I was three I had
my birthday at a McDonald's it was
awesome I didn't even think about the
Florida moccasins that were definitely
nesting in the ball pit thank you to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
watching stuff frame by frame is great
but it can also be really rewarding to
zoom out and look at things like story
pasting and character development for a
movie you can just let it play out but
when you're the target of analysis it's
better to get some help from betterhelp
regardless if you have a clinical mental
health issue like depression or anxiety
or if you're just going through a hard
time therapy can give you some tools to
approach your life in a very different
way with better help you can tap into a
network of over 30 000 licenses and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues it's easy to
sign up and get matched with a therapist
there's a link in my description it's
betterhelp.com new rockstars to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit in
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for free without
stressing about insurance or who's in
your network or anything like that you
can always benefit from talking to
somebody and getting things off your
chest so if you're struggling consider
online therapy with better help click
the link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com do rockstars clicking
that link helps support this channel but
it also gets you 10 off your first month
of Better Health but while this may be a
choice that a post Vengeance Sylvie
makes not knowing where else to go the
deliberate choice of 1982 McDonald's
might be a bit darker than we think and
no not just because I have some crazy
theory that apple pie versus Key Lime
Pie has some kind of dark Soylent Green
truth and everything Apple related
represents goodness because he remains
was eating apple Thanos in that multiple
choice prompt was eating apples and now
moobius wants an apple pie I'm not going
to talk about that here I already just
kind of did but let's rewind the clock
to that moment Sylvie stabbed he remains
she definitely had enough time after she
stabbed he who remains that she was
alone in the Citadel as she looked out
past him at the breaking Multiverse she
was able to take it all in and realize
the consequences of her decision
actually season two footage confirms
that we will revisit the moment shortly
after that stab occurred we see shots of
the broken Citadel roof and you can see
he remains corpse in his chair here but
the fact that we're seeing this new
angle of Jonathan major tells us that if
they were able to set up something new
with him there's gonna be more to this
scene where he remains might respawn or
reanimate and laugh at Sylvie's face as
he explains to her exactly what she just
did and bye see you soon he meant and a
couple seconds from now now after that
finale episode season one director Kate
Herron told below the line that he
remains didn't erase the other timelines
of the Multiverse so much as he closed
them off and isolated the timeline that
we all know from the other timelines she
said quote he's been doing that to
protect himself because he's afraid of
the other variants of himself which is
Kang the Conqueror and the many other
variants of him as well so there's many
different versions of that character in
our story it's he remains and he's a
variant of Kang but he's drawing
inspiration from a mortal this is an
interesting thing to say he's drawing
inspiration from someone who actually
does have a limited lifespan as if he
remains knew that his time and existence
was limited that he was destined to die
and then Heron went on in this interview
to say in terms of the Multiverse as he
remains explains he isolated their
timeline but now because of what
Sylvie's done it's almost like it's
going to branch and then those branches
are like Bridges to other timelines
where these other versions of he remains
will be and I think it's important to
remember this isolation not eraser he
who remains burn the bridges and now
Sylvie by doing this rebuilt those
bridges and another term for these
Bridges is incursions and it's just so
interesting to think of it this way that
these incursions are actually Bridges to
other timelines and that this will all
lead inevitably to Secret Wars but
according to he remains probably some
bridges are meant to stay burned and
still be by stabbing he remains brought
about what she thought would be the
ultimate apocalyptic vent the apocalypse
to end all apocalypses she just thought
it would all end her mind has been
framed by centuries of living in ends of
Worlds she could not possibly imagine
what would come next so we come back to
the question why would Sylvie go to work
at McDonald's in 1982 well maybe it is
just this Nice Slice of Heaven the only
thing I could really find about
McDonald's in the year 1982 was that it
was one year before chicken McNuggets
were introduced to all domestic U.S
McDonald's locations that was in 1983
and then 1983 was also the time the U.S
in USSR were in a series of terrifying
war games that had everyone feeling
super anxious to throw a nuclear
genocide was back on the table but then
I went back through my research at all
of Sylvie's dates and locations on her
list of pruning canister bombing Targets
in Loki season 1 episode 2. one of them
was October 13 1982 Titan this was a
year that Sylvie punched into her
canister 1982 meant something to her and
I always wondered if this could have
been the date of the ecological crisis
that apocalyptic event caused by
overpopulation on Titan the thing that
Thanos alluded to in Infinity war that
brought ruin to thanos's home world of
Titan now he could just look at the fact
that Thanos isn't Eternal as is his
brother Eros AKA Star Fox Harry Styles
and if the MCU has the same rules for
these eternals as they did for the Earth
eternals Thanos and Star Fox would have
been assigned to Titan to nurture the
planet's growth until Celestial hatched
out of it like maybe there was a smaller
Celestial that has had a Titan and
caused that apocalyptic disaster and
that is why Thanos wanted to reduce the
population so drastically to prevent
that from happening so if silby's sacred
timeline bomb altered that 1982 Titan
history who knows that could have led
the celestials in this what if scenario
to haste in the celestial birthing
process on Earth and Sylvie just picked
this date on Earth as the eve of
tiamat's premature hatching I'll post a
question to you do you think Loki season
2 will show us an alternate timeline
apocalyptic event on Earth in 1982.
comment down below with your thoughts
subscribe to all three channels on the
new rockstars Network you can follow me
at EA boss thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time bye
[Music]